d'une trentaine d'étudiants à une
quinzaine les travaux dirigés ce faux en
tous petits groupes
l'université versailles saint quentin en
accueille à nouveau ses étudiants depuis
ce lundi 8 février
pour ces 2e année leur premier cours de
droit pénal se fait en présentiel le
fait déjà de voir les professeurs parce
que c'est pas du tout la même chose
qu'on est chez nous toute la journée en
jogging et eau et de revoir les autres
aussi ça fait vraiment du bien d'avoir
un lien social parce que vraiment depuis
trois mois tous tout seul dans sa
chambre
c'était super même si j'habite loin j'ai
fait plus d'une heure de trajet pour
venir je me dis que ça vaut le coup
parce que ça va être vraiment pour pour
mieux comprendre le pour le contact avec
les professeurs et avec d'autres
étudiants plutôt que rester seul chez
soi c'est moins sympa un retour fait sur
la base du volontariat pour cette
première journée ils sont 300 à pouvoir
revenir dans les salles de cours
la visio est toujours proposé cette
filière accueille en temps normal trois
mille étudiants vraiment les travaux
dirigés sont des cours en petits groupes
dans lesquels une interaction est
vraiment possible entre les étudiants
entre eux et également entre les
étudiants et les forces des enseignants
c'est vraiment en td un mode
d'enseignement qui est vraiment propice
à l'interaction et vous fait que l'on
peut se nourrir des échanges les cours
magistraux sont dispensés en
visioconférence les étudiants se voient
aussi proposer une archive film est bien
qu espérer un retour à la normale n'est
pas encore envisagée par l'université